without getting into too many details
like was there ever a point in time
where like the street [ __ ] almost ended
up costing you freedom yeah yeah not a
big time
um i think that a lot of that [ __ ] will
be told um
in this series i'm doing right now i
just announced a partnership with the
creator of snowfall
the writer director from denver thieves
and the producer of game of thrones
we're doing a we're doing a scripted uh
crime series about all about pack
shipping in northern california's role
in the wii game and so a lot of them
stories will be it's based on true
events so a lot of them stories will be
in there but yeah definitely did bro
yeah it's crazy because if you think of
like and obviously like you're you know
northern california was kind of like the
hub for everyone to go out there get
their plug
and then
send packs to the midwest to the south
to just every it comes to that
granddaddy purple on that og and that
bubba kush and like
just you know even with the cookies and
gelato i mean we nor cal really changed
the game especially look at like what
humble county did before people knew
what green greenhouse or outdoor was i
mean
there's big margins my boy oh especially
on the outdoor [ __ ] yeah it was almost
like coke on you bro like because if you
think about like uh you know if you have
like some great light depth or some
great green
green house that's
on the east coast it's loud at a certain
point in time before people knew what
greenhouse was i was dog walking people
bro
margin game insane bro like
it was nice time and then the game got
changed but yeah it's different now the
margin is a period where people from the
south didn't know the difference between
indoor and outdoor let alone indoor and
greenhouse they started figuring out
outdoor because obviously it looks way
different it smells right yeah but the
good depths and the good greenhouse
would be so good sometimes that pasta
that's still going on uh yeah but not
but not to the same i'm sure in your
heyday it was man 4 800 for a pound of
green house
boy it was big